so
so
good morning good morning
i call this here in the order for many
americans
a college degree is an important goal
that can mean a lifetime at better
earnings
and opportunities however
this goal has come at a higher price the
cost of education
has risen significantly while the job
market has weakened
straining a generation of americans
seeking to establish
themselves in the broader economy
student loan debt now stands at over one
trillion dollars and a second only
to mortgage debt as the largest form of
debt in the country
student loan balances have almost
tripled
since 2004 and then
alarming one-third of borrowers are
delinquent
on their loans last year nearly
8 out of 10 students in my home state of
south dakota
graduated with student debt
these rising debts reach beyond
individuals
and impact many sectors of the economy
high levels of student loans mean
many put off on a home or never become
homeowners at all student loans make it
harder to stretch
small businesses student loan payments
often take priority over retirement
savings
and rising student loan balances in
states
like south dakota make it harder for
graduates
to stay in rural communities while most
student loans are federal
private loans make up 150 billion
dollars
of the market private lenders allow many
students
to attend college who would not
otherwise be
able to afford it and many
and may sometimes offer better terms
than federal loans however
nearly 1 million borrowers are in
default
on their private student loans and while
federal loans offer flexible relief
during periods of hardship most private
student learners
do not offer the same options for
struggling
graduates our witnesses today
represent the federal agencies
responsible
for ensuring that lenders balance some
lending principles with appropriate
measures
to avoid default i look forward to
hearing
your testimony on guidance you provide
to lenders
and what limitations lenders may face
in providing relief the cfpb
has been very active in private student
loans
recently publishing a proposal to
oversee
large student loans servicers and a
report
on affordable private student loan
repayment
i'm interested to hear from the cfpb
on both of these efforts next week
on july 1 millions of students
face a doubling of the interest rates on
some
federal loans i urge the regulators to
be vigilant
and monitoring growth in the private
student loan market that
that may result from changes to the
federal
student loan market it is critical
that regulators respond quickly to
marketplace
changes and that consumer protections
are safeguarded when demand rises
with that i turn now to reckon member
[ __ ] thank you mr chairman for
holding this hearing today
student loans play a vital role in the
lives of many students and their
families across this country
the loans help maintain a strong and
educated workforce by ensuring
that all americans can have access to
higher education
regardless of their financial
circumstances
recently the new york federal reserve
reported that student loan debt has
risen to become the second
largest household debt burden behind
mortgages
the total outstanding student debt was
986 billion dollars in the first quarter
of 2013.
just nine years ago that number was 240
billion dollars
several factors have contributed to this
student debt explosion over the last
decade
including college tuition rates that
have significantly outplaced
inflation and a record number of
students and employees opting for school
in light of the very tight job prospects
in the market
when discussing student loan the student
loan market
there's considerable confusion as to who
is making the loans and how the loans
are made
according to the cfpb 85 percent of the
total
outstanding student debt is in federal
student loans
offered through the department of
education that is roughly 838 billion
dollars
private student loans the subject of
this hearing make up 15 percent
of the outstanding debt and that market
is expected to shrink even further
a recent standard and poor's report
noted that new originations for federal
loans occupy roughly 94
of the market while private lenders
originate the remaining
six percent much of the contraction in
the private lending market is due to the
restructuring of the department of
education loan programs in 2010
to virtually eliminate private lenders
other important considerations include
the fact that federal loans default on
average
three times as often as private loans
federal loans do not undergo an
underwriting process
and there is almost limitless spending
for borrowers who take out federal loans
for graduate school
with respect to private student loans
one concern i often hear is that banks
don't offer enough borrower relief
options
in the testimony submitted today it
appears that prudential banking
regulators
and the cfpb are offering conflicting
guidance
on borrower relief options the cfpb is
pressing for more borrower relief
however the prudential banking
regulators are concerned with how
modified loans affect a bank's safety
and soundness as well
as whether they violate accounting rules
lenders have stepped up and expressed
their willingness to help more troubled
borrowers and cite that loan
modifications may benefit
both borrowers and lenders in certain
circumstances
today i hope we can get a better
understanding of the obstacles
that face us directly from the
regulators
i also would like to hear about how the
regulators are working together to
resolve this
conundrum of providing student loan
relief while not endangering the safety
and soundness of the system
finally since the vast majority of
student loans are made by the department
of education we need to acknowledge that
the committee on health education labor
and pensions
has a critical role in determining
whether the department of education
student loan programs are helping the
situation
or binding students and their families
into too much debt i know all my senate
colleagues want to find a solution to
ease the burden on our young people
mr chairman i before we conclude we
received a letter from the consumer
bankers association and a letter from
the financial services roundtable
regarding student loan issues
and i would request that both letters be
entered into the record without
objection
thank you thank you senator crapo
are there any other members who wish to
make a brief opening statement
mr president senator reid uh thank you
mr chairman uh thank you very much for
holding this hearing and uh
we are reaching a tipping point with
student loan debt as you've
and senator crapo have illustrated
particularly as we approach
life first with the potential doubling
of
loans on students who have the most need
in our country
student loan debt as both my colleagues
have indicated is really the next big
financial crisis and it could have a
lasting impact on our economic growth
and the perspectives for coming
generation
we've seen student loan debt rise
throughout the recession even as other
household debt has fallen
and student loan debt as my colleagues
have indicated is now the second largest
outstanding balance after mortgage debt
with respect to households and this is
affecting the the life trajectory of
generations of americans the young
people today and
if we don't do anything even their
children
our students are caught between a rock
and a hard place
the job market increasingly demands
post-secondary education
at the same time college is getting much
more expensive
there's been a major course shift in
higher education costs have gone up
state support for public institutions
has gone down
and as a result tuitions are rising in
fact exploding
in the federal student a program uh 68
percent
of federal student aid is in the form of
loans and
i have the privilege of holding the seat
held by claiborne pell
when senator pell introduced the pell
grants back then the mix was much
different in fact i believe was 80
percent grants and 20
loans and we have flipped turned
the whole thing over on its head
in fact many of my contemporaries were
the beneficiaries of that wonderful
80 percent loan to 20 80 percent grant
to 20
loan effort and we're not keeping up
with that at the federal level
we have to keep these loans affordable
um
low interest rates is part of solution
and again it is just distressing many of
us that
we're on the precipice of doubling the
subsidized rate from 3.4 to 6.8
in just a few days ironically
as we increase the rates and my
colleague from massachusetts as senator
warren has pointed
out again and again the federal
government is making about 50 billion
dollars this year on their loans
and expected to make a hundred billion
180 billion between now and 2023
so there's a lot of money it's just not
getting to the
young people that need it and their
families
we've got to work on both sides and we
have to recognize
that we have to be back where we were i
believe in the 50s 60s and the 70s we're
actually using federal resources to help
people get to college
not using students to pay down the debt
and many of my uh
colleagues are suggesting that we do
precise the latter not the former
so i look forward to today's testimony
the broader issue of private loans
uh but we really have a crisis that is
before us
thank you mr chairman is there anyone
else
uh senator brown thank you mr chairman i
i appreciate the uh senator reed's words
my um
my wife is the daughter of a utility
plant maintenance worker and a um and a
home care worker and she graduated first
in her family go to college from kent
state
30 i won't say how many years ago 30
plus years ago with student loan of a
student debt of about 1200
and i think that tells the story that he
mentioned um thank you to the witnesses
and thanks mr chairman senator crapo for
holding this hearing i i in 2000
november 2009 i introduced legislation
to create a private education loan
ombudsman
these provisions were part of dodd-frank
in 2010
some three and a half years later it's
gratifying to see the great work that
cfpb's first student loan ombudsman
ombudsman mr chopra is doing with with
this office thank you for that
speaking out about issues helping
borrowers get real relief
about a year ago my subcommittee held a
hearing on private student loans
uh where mr chopra and i discussed the
discrepancy between the low rates
in which banks borrow and the interest
rates that that they
charge students something that senator
reid senator warren both talked about
the example the nation's largest student
loan lender borrows an average rate of
1.45
while the average private student loan
borrower is paying more than five times
that amount
some seven point nine percent mr
chopra's testimony then noted there
to now notes that the increase in
private student loan lenders
interest margins quote may demonstrate a
lack of competition as well as an
opportunity
for more efficient private capital
participation
the president of the nation's largest
student lender said in january the
margins here
are really a function of alternative
financing opportunities
we're making loans to parents and
students family education loans
there are alternatives are fairly
limited today i
am proud to announce that
my fellow member of the banking
committee senator heidtkemp and i along
with senators durbin and murray
are introducing legislation to create
opportunities for borrowers
to refinance their private student loans
the refinancing education funding to
invest for the future act
or refi for the future would authorize
treasury secretary in consultation
with the education secretary and the
cfpb to create a program
to encourage competitions for
refinancing of private student loans the
the most indebted student borrowers are
the most likely to have
sta private private student loans of the
one trillion dollars that senator crapo
mentioned
in student loan debt about only about 15
but that's still 150 billion dollars is
in the private student loan market it's
something we can do
something about uh senator heitkamp's in
my legislation will help to do that
thank you mr does anybody else
senator hart camp um
you know a couple months ago i hosted a
housing tour across north dakota
we have an acute shortage and
affordability issues due to our economy
as things grow at the round tables that
i conducted
one issue came up over and over and over
again
which is that young people cannot get
entry into the market because they're
not bankable
and they're not bankable because they're
carrying thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars
of student debt and families talk to us
every day
and say how come at a time of record low
interest rates
we're paying eight nine ten percent on
our student
debt we cannot continue this and we know
from massive credit card interest that
if we do not
figure out a way they will continue to
pay the interest
and never get out of the principal debt
and never be bankable
never be able to get a loan to build a
business be entrepreneurial
this is is is crushing
the future of our economy if we don't
deal with it and this is a small point
obviously not the big part of student
loan issues we're concerned about the
rates
but we're also concerned about giving
those people with
private loans an opportunity to
refinance just like you would if you had
a mortgage and so
i want to applaud uh senator brown for
the work that he's done
i'm proud to be on this and i want to
thank the chairman and the ranking
members for
holding this hearing this is an issue
that won't go away
it is an issue that we will continue to
work on until we know that we have
secured
a viable future for american families
and they won't be
you know buried under with student debt
thank you mr chairman thank you all i
want to remind my colleagues that the
record will
be open for the next seven days for
opening statements
and any other materials you would like
to submit
now i will introduce the members
of the panel warhead chopra
did they pronounce that correctly close
enough
there's a certain loan ombudsman at the
financial
at the consumer financial protection
bureau
john lyons is a senior deputy
comptroller for bank supervision policy
and chief national black examiner at the
office
of the comptroller of the currency
todd fermillier is a senior associate
director
for banking supervision and regulation
at the board of governors
of the federal reserve system
during eberle is a director of risk
management supervision at the federal
deposit insurance corporation
i thank all of you again for being here
today
i would like to ask the witnesses to
please
keep your remarks for five minutes your
full
written statements will be included in
the hearing record
mr chapa you may proceed
thank you mr chairman ranking member
crapo and members of the committee for
the opportunity to testify today
it is clear that many in congress are
keenly interested in finding solutions
to some of the troubling trends in the
student loan market
understandably many policymakers across
the country are seeking to address some
of the underlying drivers
of growing student loan debt including
the rising cost of tuition
however it will also be prudent to
address the large pool of existing debt
owed by millions of americans the
consumer financial protection bureau
estimates that outstanding student loan
debt is approaching
1.2 trillion dollars while most of the
market consists of federal loans
81 percent of our high debt
undergraduate borrowers
used private student loans and like a
business
a consumer's ability to manage cash flow
is absolutely critical to financial
health
private student loan providers generally
do not
offer this cash flow management option
which is available to borrowers of
federal student loans
and for private loan borrowers who
default early in their lives
the negative impact on their credit
report can make it even more difficult
to pass employment verification checks
or ever reach their dream of buying a
home
while risks in the student loan market
do not appear to jeopardize the solvency
of the financial system
the difficulties borrowers face when
trying to manage
cash flow may have a broader impact on
the economy and society
we recently published a report on what
we heard from the public
about these potential impacts the
national association of home builders
wrote to the bureau about the relatively
low
share of first-time home buyers in the
market compared to historical levels and
that student debt
can quote impair the ability of recent
college graduates
to qualify for a loan and when young
workers are putting large portions of
their income towards student loan
payments
they are less able to stash away cash
for that first down payment
in submissions by coalitions of small
businesses
groups cited a number of factors about
the threat of student debt
for many young entrepreneurs it is
critical to invest capital to develop
ideas market products and create jobs
but high student debt burdens require
these individuals to take
more cash out of their business so that
they can make
monthly payments the american medical
association wrote that high debt burdens
can impact the career choice of new
doctors
leading some to abandon caring for the
elderly or children for more lucrative
specialties
student debt can also impact the
availability of other professions
critical to the livelihoods of rural
communities
according to an annual survey 89 percent
of veterinary veterinary students are
graduating with debt
averaging over one hundred fifty
thousand dollars per borrower
veterinarians encumbered with high debt
burdens may be unable to make ends meet
in a dairy medicine or livestock
management practice
in remote areas classroom teachers
submitted letters detailing the impact
of private student loan debt
which don't always offer the income
based repayment options or loan
forgiveness programs
when there was concern about the domino
effect of problems in the capital
markets
policy makers took action in 2008
distress in the credit markets led the
federal government to enact policies
to assist financial institutions to
raise capital for student loan issuance
while programs like the e-casla and tauf
were primarily designed to assist
financial institutions to originate more
loans
understanding them might be useful for
policy makers seeking to address
some of the market failures faced in
this market
in our recent report on student loan
affordability we discussed a number of
ideas put forth by the public
i want to briefly note two that might
increase
private capital participation and market
efficiency
the first is spurring loan restructuring
opportunities
most private student loans have few
options available for alternative
repayment plans
policy makers might look to provide a
path forward for borrowers in distress
creating a transparent step-by-step
process that leads to affordable payment
terms
where monthly payments can match a
reasonable debt to income ratio
and repayment of the loans can be more
affordable this may be helpful to
financial institutions as well
who can recognize a higher net present
value of loans in distress
the second is jump starting a student
loan refinance market
for borrowers who have dutifully managed
their monthly payments on high interest
rate loans
many raise the need for a way to
refinance
this approach could give responsible
borrowers the opportunity to swap their
loan for one with a lower rate
when mortgage borrowers and others see
rates plummet they try to refinance
responsible borrowers should have that
option too
thank you for the opportunity to share
insight on the state of the market and i
look forward to any questions you have
thank you mr chopra mr lyons
please proceed chairman johnson ranking
member cripo and members of the
committee
i appreciate this opportunity to discuss
the occ supervisory approach to private
student lending conducted by national
banks and federal associations
promoting fair and equitable access to
credit including education financing is
a core occ mission and one of our
highest priorities
financial assistance is an important
means of helping promote higher
education in this country
national banks and federal savings
associations have a long history with
federal and private student lending
programs
but they make up just three percent of
the approximately one trillion in
outstanding student loans in this
country today
however the private student loans
offered by national banks and thrifts
provide provide an important supplement
for many students seeking to finance
their educations
for most consumer loans such as auto
loans the underwriting structure and
management of the loans are
straightforward
the funds serve a specific purpose and
the sorcery payment is well defined and
easily assessed at the loan's
origination
student loans however pose unique
challenges for lenders and borrowers
for example student loans often requires
a several year commitment that extend
extends beyond when the student starts
school until repayment begins after the
education is complete
private student loans are usually
unsecured and a significant time may
pass between when the lender advances
the funds and when that student reaches
their anticipated earnings potential
in addition because the government does
not guarantee private student loans as
it does federal student loans
many lenders require cosigners to help
ensure repayment
notwithstanding the challenges of
private student lending we expect
national bank and thrift lenders to
provide flexibility to borrowers
when appropriate for example lenders
typically defer payments until borrowers
are in school
while borrowers are in school and offer
grace periods afterward to help
borrowers transition to employment
student loans are the only consumer
product with such a transition period
this flexibility reflects the unique
circumstances of the student borrower
and that these loans truly are an
investment in the borrower's future
we also encourage lenders to work with
borrowers who experience financial
hardship
that assistance may come in the form of
forbearance modification programs that
reduce
interest rates or change other terms of
the original loan or extended grace
periods that go beyond what is permitted
in other consumer loans for up to 12
months
the occ supports these efforts and
issued guidance to our examiners in 2010
describing our expectations
for managing forbearance workout and
modification programs
while the occ encourages national banks
and thrifts to work with borrowers
facing difficulties
this does not relieve these institutions
of their responsibility
to ensure that regulatory reports and
financial statements are accurate
and representative of the financial
condition of the institution
neither the public nor the banking
industry should confuse the expectation
for full and accurate reporting
as a limit on available forbearance
workout or modification programs
to be clear our student lending guidance
allows flexibility for lenders to offer
forbearance and modification programs
but requires banks to report the volume
and nature of these transactions
accurately
the flexibility to assist borrowers and
the responsibility to report these
actions accurately
are not mutually exclusive together they
promote a safe and sound banking system
my testimony concludes with the
discussion of a number of policy
recommend
recommendations to strengthen student
lending overall the occ supports
recommendations aimed at improving the
transparency of student loans
to help students and their family make
better informed decisions
likewise we support loan documents and
billing statements that are easy to read
and understand
in closing while private student lending
is a small part of the available
financial assistance in this country
it is an important part and we encourage
banks to work with troubled borrowers
during periods of hardship
thank you for the opportunity to testify
and i'd be happy to answer your
questions
thank you mr alliance mr vermoeye
please proceed chairman johnson
ranking member craipo and other members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify at today's
hearing
first i will discuss recent student loan
market trends in the portfolio
performance of both government
guaranteed and private student loans
i will then address the federal
reserve's approach to supervising
financial institutions engaged in
student lending
the student loan market has increased
significantly over the past several
years with outstanding student loan debt
almost doubling since 2007
from about 550 billion to over 1
trillion dollars today
balances of student loan debt are now
greater than any other consumer loan
product with the exception of
residential mortgages
and this is the only form of household
debt that has continued to rise during
the financial crisis
since 2004 both the number of borrowers
and the average balance per borrower has
steadily increased
in 2004 the share of 25 year olds with
student debt was just over 25 percent
and it stands at more than 40 percent
today
at the end of 2012 the average balance
per borrower was slightly less
than 25 000 compared with an average
balance of just over 15 000
in 2004.
of total student debt outstanding
approximately 85 percent is government
guaranteed in some way
while private loans represent 15 percent
of the market
while while federal student loan
originations have continued to increase
in each year
private loan originations peaked in 2008
at roughly 25 billion and have dropped
sharply to just over 8 billion in 2012.
in line with the rapid growth in student
loans outstanding
the balance of student loans private and
guaranteed
that are currently delinquent has risen
sharply standing at 11.7 percent
in 2012 a large increase from 6.3
percent in 2004
however some 44 percent of balances are
not yet in their repayment period
and if these loans are excluded from the
data pool the effective delinquency rate
of loans in repayment roughly doubles to
21 percent
of the one trillion dollars in total
outstanding student loan debt
about 150 billion consists of private
student loans
in the private student loan market
roughly five percent
or eight billion dollars is delinquent
there are likely a number of factors
underlying the difference in performance
of government guaranteed and private
student loans
for instance underwriting standards in
private student loan
market have tightened considerably since
the financial crisis
and today almost 90 percent of these
loans have a guarantor
or cosigner the federal reserve has no
direct role in setting the terms of
student loan programs
the federal reserve does however have a
window into the student loan market
through our supervisory role
over some of the banking organizations
that participate in this market
federal reserve supervision of
participants in student loan market is
similar to our supervision
of other retail credit markets and
products
for large institutions the federal
reserve regulates with significant
student loan portfolios
our on-site examiners evaluate
institutions credit risk management
practices
including adherence to sound
underwriting standards timely
recognition of loan deterioration
and appropriate loan loss provisioning
the federal reserve and other federal
banking agencies have jointly developed
guidance
outlining loan modification procedures
that discusses how banks should engage
in extensions deferrals renewals and
rewrites of closed end
retail credit loans which include
student loans
any loan restructuring should be based
on a renewed willingness
and ability to repay and be consistent
with an institution's
sound internal policies the federal
reserve
encourages its regulated institutions to
work constructively with borrowers
who have a legitimate claim of hardship
moreover
federal reserve examiners will not
criticize an institution
in institutions that engage in prudent
loan modifications
but rather view modifications as a
positive action
when they mitigate credit risk as
supervisors
our goal is to make sure that lenders
work with borrowers having temporary
difficulties
in a way that does not contradict
principles of sound
bank risk management including
reflecting the true quality and
delinquency status
of student loan portfolios higher
education plays an important role
in improving the skill level of american
workers
due to increases enrollment and the
rising costs of higher education
student loans play an important role in
financing higher education
the rapidly increasing burden of student
loan debt underscores the importance of
today's hearing
this concludes my prepared remarks and
i'd be happy to answer any questions you
have
thank you mr premier
miss everly please proceed
chairman johnson ranking mender crapo
and members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
on behalf of the fdic
on the important topic of private
student loans in today's fragile
economic environment with persistently
high levels of unemployment and
underemployment
many consumers are struggling with debt
loads from student loans both federal
and private
we understand the concerns of struggling
private student loan borrowers
and encourage the banks we supervise to
work constructively with these borrowers
while it's difficult to be precise about
the size of the private student loan
market
it is estimated that as of december 31st
2011
the market totaled about 150 billion or
15 percent of all student loans
outstanding
in the 2011-2012 academic year banks
supervised by the fdic
held about 14 billion in outstanding
private student loans and originated
about 4 billion in new loans
the fdic supervises private student loan
lenders using the same framework of
safety and soundness and consumer
protection
rules policies and guidance as for other
loan categories
the interagency uniform retail credit
classification and account management
policy or retail credit policy for short
applies to student loans as it does to
other unsecured personal loans
this policy provides institutions with
guidance on classifying retail credits
for regulatory purposes
and on establishing policies for working
with borrowers experiencing problems
private student loans held by fdic
supervised institutions are generally
performing satisfactorily
they have a past due ratio of just under
three percent and a charge off rate of
just over one and a half percent per
year
while the overall performance of these
private student loans is satisfactory
we understand that many borrowers are
currently having difficulty repaying
their loans
and we encourage the banks we supervise
to work with troubled borrowers
using the guidance provided by the
retail credit policy
the retail credit policy provides
institutions significant flexibility in
offering prudent loan modifications
institutions are responsible for
establishing their own modification
standards within the principles set
forth within the retail credit policy
they must also monitor the performance
of modified loans
to ensure that their standards are
reasonable we make clear to our
institutions that we will not criticize
banks for engaging in alternate
repayment plans
or modifications that are consistent
with safe and sound practices
in the end prudent workout arrangements
are in the long-term best interest
of both the financial institution and
the borrower
under the policies they established fdic
supervised banks offer
troubled borrowers forbearance for
periods ranging from three to nine
months
beyond the initial six-month grace
period after leaving school
in addition a number of workout plans
are also available to borrowers of
institutions we supervise
including interest rate reductions
extended loan terms
and in settlement situations principal
forgiveness
however it is important that workout
programs not leave the borrower worse
off
for example a workout that results in
significant negative amortization
can leave a borrower deeper in debt
concerns have been raised that troubled
debt restructuring accounting rules or
tdr rules
limit a bank's ability to modify student
loans
the tdr rules are established by
generally accepted accounting principles
which banks are required by law to
follow
however the tdr rules do not prevent
institutions from working with borrowers
to restructure loans with reasonable
terms
the fdic will not criticize a
restructured loan even if it's
designated a tdr
we also appreciate the significant
challenges borrowers face for
refinancing higher rate private student
loans
one of the more important challenges is
the lack of participants in the
refinance market
the fdic continues to seek solutions for
challenges in the student lending arena
in the next few weeks we intend to issue
a financial institution letter to the
banks we supervise
clarifying and reinforcing that we
support efforts by banks to work with
student loan borrowers
and that our current regulatory guidance
permits this activity
the financial institution letter will
make clear that banks should be
transparent in their dealings with
borrowers
and make certain that borrowers are
aware of the availability of workout
programs
and associated eligibility criteria
we have also formed an internal working
group to engage private student loan
lenders and consumer groups on these
issues
we are discussing our current policies
and the refinancing challenges with
other regulators to determine
whether additional clarifications or
changes of current policies may be
needed
thank you again for inviting me to
testify i look forward to your questions
thank you miss everly and thank you all
for very much for your testimony
as we begin questions i will ask the
clerk to put five minutes in the clock
for each member
this question is for the whole panel
if congress fails to act interest rates
will double on some federal
stafford loans next week
if these rates double what do you think
the impact will be
on the private student student loan
market
what steps are your agencies taken to
closely monitor the situation
in any related growth in the private
student
london market mr chopra let's begin with
you
well the change in the federal student
loan interest rates
only impacts future borrowers so it
has absolutely no impact on
private student loan borrowers who are
currently
trying to refinance trying to pay back
those loans
some industry observers would guess
that the change in the interest rates
might be a slight tailwind
to uh private loan origination but uh
i don't expect it to be a huge one
racial lines
i think what you may see in the private
loan market is
it risk-based pricing which is what they
should be doing today
risk-based pricing and i think you
should see that continuing forward
it all is predicated on the competition
within the market and what
what the competitors are pricing as well
mr burton marie
if
if loans if pricing in the
government space were to increase we
would expect that the attractiveness
the relative attractiveness of the
private prof uh products would increase
so we would expect growth in new
originations
our examiners would monitor this they
would monitor underwriting standards
they would
as the importance of the asset class
increased
their scrutiny of it would increase
commensurately
and miss everly i think that
you know there would definitely be an
impact on borrowers of the federal
program going forward as mr chopra noted
with the increase in interest rates
um but the impact on the private market
i think is really unclear as noted by mr
alliance the private market does engage
in risk-based pricing
and so the pricing of the federal loan
product is not
really a factor in the private loan
product
i would add that i would expect that
students would
continue to try to exhaust federal loans
first before moving to private loans
uh just because of the um
available options under the federal loan
program for repayment and rehabilitation
in particular that aren't available
under the private program
mr lyons uh followed by
mr abramier and miss herberly
the agencies do not have public guidance
tailored to private student learning
instead
relying on an interagency policy
and retail credit that was last updated
over
13 years ago some have
suggested that this guidance prevents
private lenders from grinding
appropriate relief
to struggling borrowers what flexibility
do lenders have
in working with borrowers to prevent
default
and what additional steps will your
agencies
take to provide clear up-to-date
loan workout guidance for private
student
lenders mr alliance the senator the
the interagency guidance as you said was
was prepared 13 years ago the occ in
2010
provided some additional guidance to our
examiners which addressed forbearance
workout programs and so on
and it was really driven by the fact
that banks were not
properly recording transactions workout
transactions and
forbearance transactions on their books
so we provided examiners for
clarification and further guidance and
as i said that was in 2010
having said that banks and we continue
to encourage
banks to work with customers there's
nothing in the guidance either the
the uniform retail guidance or the occ
guns that prevents a bank
from working with a customer the bank
however does have the responsibility of
properly recording that transaction on
their books
mr bremery do you have anything to add
and articulates uh
timeless principles of risk management
it is not a prescriptive piece of
guidance it does not uh declare
certain types of things out of bounds or
but but instead encourages
borrowers to i'm sorry banks to work
with their borrowers
uh when they can
reaffirm the ability and willingness of
the borrower to repay
this everly i believe that the retail
credit policy guidance does offer
institutions the flexibility to work
with borrowers and in fact
are the institutions that the fdi
supervises have used that flexibility
and offer a range of workout programs
the the one that i highlighted earlier
was a differing range of um
forbearance after the initial six-month
grace period it ranges from three to
nine months in the institutions we
supervise
so we we have not set forth anything um
concrete or prescriptive but our
institutions are using the flexibility
and the guidance in the way that it was
intended
senator crapo thank you mr chairman
mr chopra last month the bureau
published a report on the effects of
student debt on young people's economic
futures and in that report you make
several policy recommendations including
spurring a more robust refinancing
market
offering more relief options and a
possible
credit report clean slate program
it's my understanding that some of these
proposals may require legislative
changes
have you heard from the lenders and the
regulators about the merits of these
programs
and do you believe that the lenders
currently have the tools and legal
authority to participate in these
programs
well all of those suggestions that we
put forth in the report were a summary
of public comments that we receive and
many of them in fact
would not require legislation
in order to maximize the value of a
troubled loan portfolio
banks and other financial institutions
generally go through the process of
identifying
interventions that would increase the
net present value
of those loans as the other panelists
have mentioned
restructuring those loans is something
where safety and soundness
as well as helping borrowers seem to go
hand in hand and i
share the concern of many investors
both equity and debt who would like to
see
financial institutions maximize the
value of these portfolios it also
ensures that
those customers become lifelong loyal
customers
and can continue to bank with that
institution
borrowing mortgages auto loans and other
things that may provide
higher net income to that institution
thank you and for the other for the
regulators the other regulators
uh i've heard from many lenders that
they're they
are willing to offer more relief options
however if the lender does modify a
student loan then they have to account
properly for modifications on their
books under the gaap accounting
standards
and a high number of modifications could
signal to the prudential banking
regulators
that the lender's loan portfolio is not
safe or sound
thus we have a situation in which the
cfpb
is advocating for certain relief options
that may not
be possible under current guidance and
prudential banking regulations
uh first of all is that correct and how
can
lenders offer loan modifications without
running a foul
of the safety and soundness and
accounting standards that they now must
qualify under or or must pursue
mr lyons senator
we encourage banks to work with
customers when there are when they
get have financial hardships that would
be reflective in the portfolio
regardless of whether they did that or
not
so whether it was a tdr or not you would
probably have a pass-through loan and a
delinquent loan so it would still be
the risk would still be identified in
the portfolio so we encourage banks to
work with customers before they get to
the point
where it's severely delinquent banks do
have the flexibility of
offering a number of different programs
but as we did say they are responsible
for accurately
reporting those transactions on their
balance sheet they have a fiduciary
responsibility to their depositors
investors and shareholders that they
accurately report
the risk profile of those portfolios
thank you mr bromeliad
so very similar we we expect our banks
to work with
borrowers in a way that benefits both
the bank and the borrower
a a restructured loan that is performing
is far better than
for everyone than a severely delinquent
loan or a charge-off
we also expect banks to follow basic
principles of sound risk management
typically for a bank that has a large
portfolio of restructured loans we would
expect them to segregate these loans
from
from others on their balance sheet and
then monitor the risk characteristics of
this portfolio
understand the probability of default
understand the loss giving default
and then hold appropriate reserves and
capital if a bank could demonstrate
with their data that these loans
performed in the same way as
past credits then that would be a
perfectly appropriate outcome
but we always expect banks to follow
accounting guidelines as well
thank you ms really i would agree with
everything my fellow fellow panelists
have said that um you know when you have
a troubled debt restructuring you by
definition have a troubled debt to begin
with
so the actual accounting design
designation of a tdr
really doesn't impact the examiner's
view of
whether or not the debt was troubled to
begin with it does
impact the examiner's view about the
bank's ability to work with that
borrower in turn
a problem situation into a better
situation by definition
a troubled debt restructuring indicates
that the bank is working with the
borrower
taking a bad situation and trying to
find a way out
um it is important that we we our
examiners do take a look on the back end
um as mr vermillion noted of an
institution's
um results with their troubled debt
restructurings with their modifications
to make sure that modification programs
are reasonable and are ending up in
a result that is good for both the
consumer and the bank
thank you thank you mr chairman senator
reid
thank you very much mr chairman
mr chopra you are responsible for
coordinating with department of
education
and also you are responsible for
reviewing the services is that correct
the people who are servicing these loans
yes the bureau has
a number of initiatives with the
department of education and
has supervisory authority over large
financial institutions over 10 billion
dollars in assets for consumer financial
laws with
with servicing operations as well as uh
we have proposed
uh supervision of certain large non-bank
services well what
let me ask a question to what extent are
these loans held by services
in sort of trust arrangements as was
common with mortgage securities
or held directly by financial
institutions so that they can in fact
negotiate with their customer directly
yeah so in private student loans i would
say roughly half
are held uh in abs trusts
where there is a master servicer and
appropriate guidelines and governing
those changes to the notes what
would apply a key difference between
subprime mortgage mbs or
private student loan abs is that it
appears that
the servicers generally speaking have
more discretion
relatively speaking to in the mortgage
world
of conducting certain interventions that
may maximize the value
for those debt investors uh
are they taking those advantages from
your perspective now as you get ready to
regulate them
well our oversight solely relates to
consumer financial laws
there is certainly activity to
restructure
certain loans within uh certain players
that hold
that service asset-backed securities
whose underlying assets is private
student loans but
i think in general uh the activity
of modifying or restructuring debt that
may be in the best interest
of the debt investor and the uh borrower
is troublingly low troubling hello thank
you mr lyons
do you supervise both the banks and the
services
that are part of the whole uh holding
companies you supervise how do you how
does that
well if it's conducted in the national
bank we do supervise the national bank's
activities whether it's on the bank's
books or if it's being serviced by the
national bank we'll look at that
activity as well
and is it common for
banks to maintain a loan on their books
as performing because they hope
ultimately to collect something since
these loans aren't dischargeable in
bankruptcy
student loans are not dischargeable in
bankruptcy that does not mean that the
bank should not in
under certain circumstances show
impairment or charge that loan off if
it's not perfect do they routinely show
impairment
or do they assume that one they will
collect eventually
under accounting rules can they under
accounting rules uh that we
enforce we expect the bank to show
impairments and to take charge offs
uh uh when they become past due over 120
days regardless of whether or not
there's
an ingress what is that what is the
general record of impairment of student
loans today in the
in the institutions you supervise so low
so there's eight banks eight national
banks to conduct uh
private student lending each one of
those banks has engaged in some type of
workout or forbearance the number is not
very large
okay the performance in those portfolios
has been pretty good
as we said earlier the past due rates
are generally in the three to four
percent range
and the loss rates are generally around
four or four and a half percent so the
performance has been relatively good
that is of this uh vintage loans
uh that's the entire portfolio so that
will cover all vintages
okay and is there any difference between
those loans held by the institution and
those held by a servicer affiliate of
the institution
uh the i'm not sure what the service
portfolios the the
delinquency rates there are what i
quoted you was what's on bulk
uh mr vermillion how about the servicer
portfolio since the holding company
would presumably be a holding company
subsidiary
are you noticing high levels of default
and or
high levels of modification well
that the data that we have is very
similar to that cited by a
colleague from the occ we don't have
data that distinguishes the delinquency
and default rate for
loans where the servicer is separate uh
we can follow up on that please do so
but i again i just want to confirm mr
chopper from your perspective yet
your point was that you're not seeing
the kind of modifications
numbers that would follow from the
the loan crisis that you're seeing in
terms of uh delinquencies is that
a fair statement i don't want to uh the
there's of course usages of forbearance
as the other panelists have mentioned
but i i don't think there's
a significant amount of concessions
given by lenders
appropriately uh noting that in their
accounting statements and then redoing
the loan
it's a very low volume thank you
senator warren
thank you mr chairman uh as we've seen
in recent studies
and as some of our witnesses have
testified today private student loans
carry high
interest rates they're difficult to
restructure and
in many cases they have created a
barrier
for people trying to buy their first
homes
and that's why i was surprised that a
federal home loan bank has been making
available
an 8.5 billion dollar line of credit to
the nation's largest
private student loan company sally may
the federal home loan banks were
established to expand home ownership
but now it seems that they are
undermining that goal
by helping finance more student loan
debt
in addition the federal home loan banks
get extraordinarily
cheap access to capital thanks to
government sponsorship and that cheap
capital was provided to sally may and
let's be specific
on this sally may has been getting
this line of credit for one
third of one percent interest
and then turning around and lending
money to students
at a rate about 20 times higher than
that
so yesterday i sent a letter to fhfa
acting director ed demarco because he
regulates the federal home loan banks
but you're all experts so i want to ask
you about this too
does it make any sense for a fortune 500
company that makes high profit student
loans
to be able to borrow money for less than
one third
of one percent from a program
that has federal backing for home
ownership
mr alliance how about if we start with
you
senator the occ does not regulate um i
understand that
so i understand that i'm not familiar
with that program
but but i'm asking you the fundamental
question you're getting money at a third
of one percent
right and then turning around and
lending it to students
at many multiples of that so
senator and national banks can i please
speak to national banks they
the the the rates that the national
banks are charging for private student
loans today
are comparable to what are being charged
for federal loans
um so there is a spread there national
banks are offering rates
libor plus relatively the same as
federal loans so they're
telling me it's like federal loans which
this year will make 51 billion dollars
in profits for the federal government
i'm not sure i find that reassuring
uh uh burley you have any comment on the
question about
uh the federal home loan bank boards
uh lending to sally may at a third of
one percent
so i think the um the issue you're
raising is is a public policy
issue the federal home loan bank is
authorized to
make loans that are secured by the
former
federal loan program collateral so loans
that were issued by
institutions with a federal guarantee so
that is allowed
um i'm not asking the question whether
or not they they behaved illegally
i'm i'm really asking the question if
they're there to promote home ownership
i think we've heard from our witnesses
today
that home ownership is maybe undermined
that there's data suggesting that
homeownership is
undermined by the growing amount of
student
loan debt and so i see the federal home
loan
bank board seems to be heading in
opposite directions
uh at the same time mr chopra you have
any comment on this
i have no idea hit your button
oh i'm sorry i i have no idea about that
the appropriateness of that arrangement
it is true though that data would
suggest that
student loan borrowers are now less
likely uh
to have a mortgage all right well that's
a that's a helpful point in it
but really worrisome about the policy
that we're following here
let me ask another question i understand
when we first started why we called
student loans subsidized but this year
the government will profit
51 billion dollars from the student loan
program
the new loans will make a profit of 184
billion dollars over the next 10 years
and it turns out that even the uh
so-called
subsidized loans uh make a profit of
about 14 cents
on the dollar the student interest rate
is scheduled to double july 1st and so
the question i have is why do we call
these loans
subsidized i i don't get this why are
they called subsidized
mr lyons senator you're referring to the
federal program that the national banks
don't lend into they lend into the
private market so i'd be happy to
discuss the private market
i i i take that as as uh
a no mr chopra well the reason why it is
called subsidize is because in the old
bank based program where they gave
federal loans that were guaranteed the
government
paid subsidies to the financial
institutions
for interest accrued during periods such
as being in school
are we doing that anymore no that
program has ended so we call these
subsidized loans
even though today the program has been
completely changed and in fact is making
a profit for the us government
so i i just want to say you know this
just seems wrong to me mr chairman
the government lends to banks at three
quarters of one percent
interest then does a huge markup on
student loans will make 51 billion
dollars
in profits this year sally may borrows
at one
third of one percent in a program that
is supported by the federal government
and then does a markup on student loans
it's time for the government to stop
making a profit off our students
thank you mr chairman senator brown
um thank you mr chairman uh mr chopra
give me your thoughts on our
on our refinancing uh refi for um
for the for the future act and in
answering some of the questions
and concerns on the 150 billion
outstanding dollars
and for the future what this means for
for private
bank loans so uh
without knowing specifics i can say that
it is
absolutely important that we address the
large population of existing borrowers
and not just the new borrowers many of
those existing borrowers were
were certainly victims of a financial
crisis that they played no role
uh in creating and they wonder why
they've been
unable to take advantage of today's
historically low rates and and just as
in 2008 there were
market failures that provided for
temporary authorities
to ensure financial institutions could
originate loans that there's no
authorities
uh currently to jumpstart that sort of
market so it seems that it's worthy of
very careful consideration
well thank you i i this is for for all
of you i
student loan debt is is a number of
people have pointed out uh senator crapo
and the chair and others that
is the second largest form of consumer
debt behind mortgages and i
i see some similarities between these
these two
uh these two issues these two um
lending institutions in some sense if
you will the the biggest banks we
we hear repeatedly finding out more
information last week
are doing a generally poor job complying
with the national settlement over their
improper foreclosure practices
um homeowners have had same with the
some same
some of the same problems that
responsible student loan borrowers
are having they re they can't refinance
they can't negotiate a deal for an
alternative repayment arrangement with
the
institution with whom they have their
mortgage um
but some large financial institutions
are at least trying to
pursue some mortgage modifications to
stem their losses so
um and so but but with the student loan
market it doesn't seem like that
refinancing is
happening with with very very very few
exceptions
despite the federal reserve's testimony
quote that student loan modifications
are generally in the best interest
of both the institution and the borrower
can lead to better loan performance
increased recoveries reduced credit
risks
and that they'll view such modifications
as a positive action when they mitigate
credit risk so
so even though the regulatory bodies are
saying this makes sense for banks
to begin to refinance some of this 150
billion dollars
in outstanding student mortgage debt why
why i understand this is a small
portfolio for citibank or for some of
these large institutions the student
loan
market is not very large relatively for
them but
each of you answer why why are the banks
not willing when when regulators are
saying this makes sense when common
sense say
suggests that this makes sense to
refinance why are the large banks
simply not coming to the table to
refinance these student loans
i'll start with you
certainly yeah it's it's a good question
why there's not an active refinance
market for student debt
there's nothing in regulatory policy or
practice that prohibits
borrowers from refinancing their student
debt none of the institutions that fdic
supervises uses prepayment penalties
or anything that would prevent a
borrower from actually engaging in a
refinance
part of it may be that the interest
rates relative to other unsecured
consumer debt
available through banks is is actually
priced a little higher
than student debt is so that may be one
factor
uh the underwriting criteria used by the
institutions that fdic supervises
usually requires a guarantor
which means the debt is underwritten at
a rate that reflects that you've already
got an established borrower
listed on the debt so so you're you may
be starting out with a low rate to begin
with
based on that established credit history
as opposed to a student on their own
um so that doesn't address any maybe
legacy loans that are that are
outstanding that are at higher rates of
interest or that weren't
guaranteed you know so it is unclear why
there's not an active
market to meet a apparent demand
um so i think the proposal is very
interesting is something we'd be
interested in working with you on mr
vermillion i mean
it did sort of this issue of too big to
fail with these largest banks it's
coming back again is it
is this sort of a too big to care sort
of situation with these
with these large banks with a relatively
smaller portfolio they just
they're just sort of disdainful of doing
anything with these with refinancing
student loans
i i don't think it's too big to care
i think they're interested in profit
opportunities where they can find them
i would associate myself with the the
response from the fdic it's not
clear why this isn't happening more our
regulatory policy would certainly uh
permit it and indeed encourage
appropriate uh workouts so
it like the fdic we're interested
in in exploring this further mr lyons
senator i would echo the comments of my
fellow regulators i think also it may
reflect possibly some market
inefficiencies like competition
as well as ms everly said many of the
student loans private student loans
today are priced off of a
cosigner so they are actually at a lower
rate than would normally be the
situation
so you know that may also factor into
why we're seeing low uh refinancing
opportunities
sure well as you mentioned
net income from private student loans is
a very small
fraction for large financial
institutions and
and as we note in our report many of
those financial institutions senior
management
is still addressing legacy issues of
troubled portfolios particularly in the
residential mortgage space
that may be occupying significant
management bandwidth
as well as their issues with the
flexibility and agility with their i.t
and accounting systems
all right uh and mr trump were your
comments earlier about
you know the the the establishing what
puzzles me further about this that you
mentioned earlier was that
these large institutions these
institutions that are simply nuts that
seem indifferent
to if not hostile to refinancing
are are the same institutions that would
i would think would want these young
people who to whom they
who want them this money to be lifelong
customers and get a mortgage someday
when they can pay off their student
loans and start businesses and all the
things and
and use these banks with whom they have
a relationship but that doesn't seem to
be the case thank you mr chairman
senator merkley
thank you mr chair and i'm i'm going to
start by addressing something as we were
sitting here
the supreme court released a ruling
eviscerating the voting
rights act and deeply
disturbed about that the strategy of
voter
suppression has been used against blacks
latinos elderly the poor
immigrants we had a situation in our
history where new york city politicians
held registration days on jewish
holidays to keep jewish
individuals from voting we have had
all kinds of forms of efforts to
not embrace the full ability of of
citizens to participate in our democracy
and today we have
strategies that include voter id laws
the reduction of early voting hours the
drawing of discriminate discriminatory
districts
and so we are not in an era free
of a strategy to to block people's
ability to participate as full citizens
and i think it's deeply disturbing the
5-4 decision that just came out is is
deeply disturbing
the topic we're addressing right now on
the the
cost of student loans it seems like we
have a new form of debtors prison
for our students uh because the loans in
combination with the interest rates
means individuals are having to delay
living independently delay marriage
if they can't get a loan to buy a house
or if they do their credit
score because of the the debt that they
carry is higher so they have to pay a
lot more in interest to buy a home
can't get along to start a business
may be disadvantaged in employment
interviews
all of these are factors that that
compromises one's ability to
to thrive and
one of the pieces that's disturbing to
me is these private loans vary their
interest rates according to
the credit background of the applicant
even though
the loans are guaranteed which means
that if you come from a background in
which you
have less wealth the you are going to
have pay a higher price over a very long
period of time
to get an education thus
locking in inequities from one
generation to the next
are are any of you disturbed by that
bias in the system
and if so what do you think we should do
doreen or ms eberly perhaps we can start
with you
um so i i may have under misunderstood
the question but
uh the private student loans that that
we have supervisory responsibility for
the lenders that make those loans
those loans share a similarity with
federal student loans in that they're
not dischargeable in bankruptcy
but they are not guaranteed by the
government so
that is a is a key distinction so the
institutions bear the risk of loss
for a default on those loans
institutions are offering the
institutions that we supervise are
offering
a choice of either a variable or a fixed
rate of interest
at the onset of the lending agreement so
the
current variable rate of interest range
is between three and nine percent
uh the fixed rate between about five and
a half and eleven and a half
is it fair to say someone from a
background
where they have less less wealth less
assets is more likely to pay the nine
percent than the three percent
and therefore pay a much higher price
for their education
so it is it is true that an individual
that had
a um a less strong credit history
would pay a higher rate of interest so
yes
the answer is yes it's risk based yes
based on it on the individual's credit
history
i take i take your point on the national
guarantee and thank you for uh
pointing out anyone is does this bother
anyone else
well uh senator merkley the private
student loans are often
underwritten uh to the fico score
and income of a cosigner so for
borrowers whose parent say
is not very credit worthy they in fact
would have
a higher rate when they were freshmen
and i think that many of them wonder
once they do graduate and land a very
good job
they wonder that given that their risk
profile may have considerably shrunk
they have developed their own credit
history why they may
why they're unable to find a product in
the market that is a lower risk adjusted
price
and they wonder about that because
they're not able to to refinance
that's right and i think many of them uh
see the incredible
savings that uh perhaps the
their parents who may be homeowners
who've been able to refinance given
today's historically low interest rates
does does this system in in general as
we've described it here
uh create extra hurdles for those who
who
come to the education marketplace with
poor assets
well there's certainly uh issues with
market efficiency when
risk does when price does not seem to
match risk
which seems to be an issue mr lyons is
there a
kind of a bias that reinforces uh
differences in background
senator i i don't know that answer i do
i would echo what um
durian eberly indicated as we expect
banks to risk price they do risk price
to the extent a student
utilizes all of his federal grants and
loans and then has to move to
a student loan uh private student loan
that loan would be risk brace priced
over if you have a loan that's nine
percent versus one that's three percent
would be fair to say that by and large
the cost of the loan is going to be
three times as high
not necessarily three times but it will
be more expensive yes the interest
the interest rate is three times as high
the interest rate is three and thus uh
a low income student a student with
parents who are co-signing who have a
poor credit background might pay three
times as much in interest
over the course of the loan to the
extent um
it's a higher risk the bank would charge
a higher rate of return yes thank you
thank you mr chair senator heidtkepp
thank you mr chairman um just a couple
points and i
don't remember if it was mr lyons or mr
uh
formulae who gave us the side by side
comparison 2004
to today i think it was it was you
um you might want to add another
statistic to your
record there 55
of all private loans in uh
in 2000 in 2005 had a cosigner
today it's 90 percent we're not only
mortgaging our kids future
we're mortgaging their parents future
their grandparents future
and we're putting their home ownership
and their retirement at risk
this is a big issue um the issue of
co-signing and so i just
i just raised that because i think it's
important to put that
on the table um a couple a couple issues
um
one on transparency and one on um a
recent
visit that i had in north dakota where i
had a chance to sit in the car and
actually
listen to the radio and this is for mr
chopra um have you seen the 1 800
numbers or heard the 1 800 numbers get
yourself out of student debt trouble
we're here to help they they sound a lot
like the predatory lending that we've
experienced over the last how many years
with
home mortgages or consumer debt credit
card debt
and i see an entrance now an opportunity
to move into that market
by people are engaged in predatory
lending practices and i'm wondering if
you guys are monitoring that
paying attention if there's anything
congress should be doing right now
to you to educate students but us to get
out ahead of it on a regulatory basis
well we're certainly familiar of the
increase in uh
debt collection and debt relief
activities as
the conditions in the student loan
market for many have been
been quite challenging for borrowers who
have federal student loans
they are marketed services to pay a
fee to enroll in certain programs
that may help them get out of default
through the department of education
which may be at no cost so of course we
are looking to
educate consumers and ensure that uh
all financial services providers are
complying with the law
just to follow up one suggestion that i
would have and i know budgets are
limited but
the ability to advertise on the same
platform
to educate on the same platform is
critical because
what what they're not advertising to
kids on you know
790 talk radio they're advertising to
those parents who have co-signed those
loans
and that's a big concern that i have um
i want to mr lyons you raised a very
important
point i think on transparency anyone who
recently has had a mortgage has sat down
for almost an hour and a half
and done all the due diligence signed
all of the you know
awareness yes we know we're mortgaging
away our life
um you know frequently what happens to a
kid and their parents on student loans
is that the
the paper gets slid across the desk and
sign on the bottom line if you want a
better future
and for a lot of specially first
generation um
uh college goers that you know there
isn't maybe a level of sophistication on
what the alternatives are
and so i'm wondering if if anyone on the
panel but particularly you mr lyons
since you raised the issue
have some suggestions for what we can do
to promote more transparency in the
private marketplace
and you know whether that should be
mandated encouraged or
otherwise um you know talked about
thank you senator uh i would agree with
the the recommendations that the
cfpp put forth regarding uh disclosure
and
clear transparency how do we get banks
to do that and i think banks have taken
steps
over the last several years since the
crisis to improve transparency and so
there is
um discussions before during and after
that they provide the students and the
students family
whereas in the past that may not have
been the case i one thing i would
suggest and and i
my time is short and that's why i'm
interrupting and i'll follow up with
some additional questions but
this needs to be done in conjunction
with institutions of higher learning
i have a student right now in north
dakota who has a hundred thousand
dollars of private debt
he's a first generation student he has a
music major and he's living in his
parents basement
as parents i'm sure on the hook for that
same level of debt
he'll never retire that debt he'll never
get out from underneath it and we've
we've guaranteed that by not
discharging this debt in bankruptcy and
so with a little bit of education about
you know what that education is worth
compared to earning power into the into
the future
and what we need to do to educate kids
not only
as they pursue their dreams but taking a
look at what the earning power are
of the choices they make in terms of
education opportunities
and so i think you're only one part of
the problem i wouldn't say problem
but you're only one part of the solution
which is here it is
financial literacy but back it up with
also education on what the earning
potential is
for these students and maybe banks can
be part of encouraging that as well
thank you mr chairman senator mentioned
thank you so much mr chairman
uh we were talking about public policy
and i'd like to get your input since
you're part of the public
um i think we're hearing from all of us
that
we believe that education being and the
facts are overwhelming the education
adds to the value of not only the person
their well-being their families their
communities their state and the nation
we all i believe have that agreement
we're all products of it probably
with that being said is your is your
opinion that
we should not make a profit on education
when it comes to loans
that's a public policy we've got to make
that we need your input
so if i can just start with you man
well in the um so i'm not sure if you're
talking about in the federal sector i'm
talking about
every sec public policy do you believe
public policy should be
that profits should be not be made on
education loans of any kind
so if we can just kind of pay itself and
break even
or you put the same procedures and the
same policies in place as you do
any other type of loans i think it's
it's an interesting question and i think
you'd have to differentiate
between the federal sector and the
private sector and answering that
question well in the in the process
public policy is public policy yeah
so maybe your cost is a little different
maybe your whole
policies are a little different but
there's still spread
there's a spread taking a lot of things
in consideration
do you believe that spread should be
zero or minimized to the point to where
there's no
that's i just i'm just asking i think it
would be hard to
calculate a zero spread on the private
side just because the institutions bear
the risk of loss
um so there's not the government uh
guarantee you don't you don't have a
public opinion then on
so i you know i i i it's really not my
area of expertise and
you have an opinion you're public you're
gonna you have representatives
congress and the senate what would you
say to your congressman and senator
uh you know i'd have to think about it i
haven't thought through this
in the private markets we need to
take many factors into consideration one
is credit availability i think the
simple i'm just asking a simple
public policy do you believe here we set
do you believe that we should not
make a profit if we can keep from making
a profit on trying to educate
this great society of ours my concern
would be that if there were a mandated
zero spread for example
that that there may not be credit
availability in the
public so you're saying that basically
in the po in the public pro
public sector private sector that the
almighty profit on
every aspect of life is going to prevail
i'm just i'm i'm not being i'm a
i'm a private business person i'm just
saying you have to put your priorities
where your values are
if education is what's built this
country education has this is the
greatest country on earth
how do we get there and have we left
that premise and is everything the
almighty dollar
the bottom line to the point where we're
trying to educate the masses
it's a public policy you're going to
talk you're talking i'm your senator
what do you want me to do
so i education policy is not
in the remit of the federal reserve and
the governors have not spoken on this
issue so this is a matter for congress
now you know why we have a stalemate in
congress now because we can't even get
the public to engage that's that's and i
know
you're looking and you have to be
careful what you're saying i'm just
trying to get input
sir well i'm not going to expand the
discussion much further senator
um i i don't think it's appropriate for
a prudential regulator to take a
policy position having said that i think
i would echo with
the two other regulators indicated that
it would be difficult to attract capital
to a business that doesn't provide some
profit to the investors and you think
just the consideration
you think that basically the american
public and the investors in american
society
would not invest in education knowing
that it would be a zero return
that that's i think that's a possibility
that has to be weighed michelle
well senator the i agree with others
that
investors will not be able to earn a
return on equity if
they cannot earn any margin but as it
relates to your general question of
profitability the only thing i can add
is
there is data from a number of sources
that do
that does suggest uh there are positive
externalities of a highly educated
workforce in the in the sense of global
competition
wage growth and others and and certainly
policymakers may consider that
um when developing policies to uh
promote
a highly educated workforce yeah i'm
talking primary and secondary education
we're mandated by the constitution
almost every state to subsidize and pay
for
which i agree wholeheartedly and we all
do that willingly higher education
there's not a word in my constitution in
west virginia that says that we have to
give a penny towards that
so our founding fathers a long time ago
thought this was a high value
good return and we got involved and we
do
we're talking about a financial program
that doesn't
cost we're not subsidizing we're not
asking someone to pay it'll pay for
itself
should we remove the profit where
possible and i think that's where
senator warren officers now can we find
that balance somewhere
so we can all be satisfied that you can
still have enough money
that we can keep the program alive but
we still have taken the
amount of profit out that it puts the
back the burden on the backs
of productivity i think that's it in a
nutshell and that's what we're coming to
and we've got to
since we're not getting much help from
the from the input
from our constituents we've got to be
able to cipher through this one to
find a bounce between our colleagues on
both sides of the aisle thank you mr
chairman
i want to thank our witnesses for their
testimony today
and for their hard work on this
important issue
this hearing is adjourned
thank you
okay
thank you very much thank you it was a
pleasure
you can